dans cette furie de temps la mère s'est
vidée de toute présence humaine
ou presque
car ils sont quelques-uns à attendre
depuis des mois à cet instant précis ne
sont pas nombreux une douzaine seydoux
cinglé malades fou dingue comme vous
voulez son wind surf où il arrive des
cinq continents et sont là pour en
découdre avec cette tempête avec le
cyclone jaune c'est la red bull sanchez
une compétition qui réunit l'élite
mondial de windsurf lors des plus gros
coup de tabac
ce cyclone irlandais est un cadeau
c'est un événement très compliqué à
organiser la tempête a été annoncé il ya
seulement trois jours
il a fallu réunir ici tous ces surfeurs
venant des quatre coins de la planète et
ça a marché tout le monde est là ce
matin c'est comme un rêve pour nous
ressemblent vraiment une tempête
les vagues viennent de très loin et
elles sont monstrueuses je suis même pas
sûre qu'on y arrive
[Musique]
m
on essaye de ride et en prenant des
précautions mais les conditions sont
tellement extrême
c'est vraiment difficile c'est comme
l'enfer sur terre vraiment c'est le
meilleur moyen de décrire ce qui se
passe ici pour rouler c'est très très
fort et à 62 ans
[Musique]
au milieu des banlieues relents à près
de 140 km heure ils me font penser à ces
albatros des mers du sud qui semble
vouloir à tout prix pro l'ailé crête des
vagues au lieu de se tenir à l'écart
[Musique]
ces hommes enchaînent les sont les
figures là où touche chercheur est
simplement à survivre comme un pied de
nez à la tempête
d'une manière générale l'homme est plus
un dans cette situation ils courbent
l'échiné au mieux mais en place les
moyens de sauver ce qui peut l'être